bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau 7 8 week-end nous allons
revenir pendant 26 minutes sur les
moments forts de l'actualité culture
loisirs et sport de la semaine au cours
de cette émission nous allons tout
d'abord évoquer avec Sylvie Leona
directrice d'Yvelines tourisme la
deuxième édition de parole de jardinier
qui s'écoule jusqu'au 29 septembre
pendant encore deux semaines vous allez
pouvoir découvrir les plus beaux parcs
et jardins du département Sylvie Laona
bonjour ou les Yvelinois vont-ils
pouvoir aller ce week-end et le week-end
qui reste derrière alors il y a
énormément de choses à faire ce week-end
d'autant que vous avez vu la météo comme
moi il fait un temps magnifique il faut
en profiter on ne sait pas ce que nous
réserve le suivant donc vous pouvez
aller à Versailles au domaine de Madame
Elisabeth et là vous allez décorer vos
tables réveillez vos assiettes avec des
fleurs puisque vous avez des chefs qui
vont vous apprendre à cuisiner des
fleurs et vous allez même les goûter
donc ça quelque chose d'un petit peu
insolite après il y a Port-Royal
Deschamps donc c'est c'est ce weekend
c'est c'est dans les parages c'est pas
loin
dimanche on vous propose de découvrir
les ruches de Port-Royal le jardin
bulloyer des jeux de piste pour les
enfants
c'est un endroit magnifique un jardin
magnifique et un potager donc avec la
famille on peut aller effectivement à
Port-Royal ce weekend et puis il y a
d'autres endroits comme ce que dans la
vallée de Chevreuse un jardin au naturel
un potager au naturel qui était
écologique et qui qui propose aussi des
insectesodrome insectodrome c'est des
petits hôtels à insectes on leur permet
d'être hébergés entre guillemets dans
des petites maisons comme ça ils vont
pas sur le potager c'est vraiment
naturel il y a pas de d'insecticides
après il y a le parc du douaire à
Boisset ce parc fait partie des espaces
naturels sensibles qui sont gérés par le
département des Yvelines avec des
espaces des espèces d'arbres
extraordinaire on va vous raconter
toutes ces toutes ces espèces au parc du
douaire à Boisset à Elsa Triolet dans le
sud du département dans la maison d'Elsa
Triolet Aragon à Saint-Arnoult tout à
fait au sud le fameux péage mais là
c'est pas la même chose c'est là
on part presque en vacances c'est l'art
du jardin que l'on va qu'on va découvrir
ou le Jardin des Arts donc encore
quelque chose de différent et puis c'est
autre chose on est dans l'aspect zen un
peu décontraction la poésie c'est
quelque chose de complètement différent
parce que tout ce que je vous propose va
marquer est différent et à Andrésy par
exemple au parc de loisirs des
cardinettes là il y aura un troc au
plante aux graines
aux différentes espèces que l'on peut
avoir envie d'acheter et puis pour les
enfants il y aura des des jeux aussi
pour ne pas ne pas qu'il s'ennuie
pendant que vous vous faites votre
propre plan voilà du côté de Chambourcy
il y a quelque chose de totalement
opposé une sorte de désert
expliquez-nous un petit peu le concept
il y a tout dans les Yvelines même des
déserts et ça c'est à l'année où vous
pouvez y aller c'est sur réservation
soit dans les offices de prise de Poissy
du pays des impressionnistes ou de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye ou à la mairie de
Chambourcy alors c'est un parc avec des
folies ce qu'on appelle des fabriques
des folies donc tout au long du parc
vous avez la colonne détruite ou le la
maison des anciens propriétaires et
c'est dans un parc merveilleux c'est un
désert parce que c'est conceptuel le nom
mais c'est pas vraiment un désert et on
découvre des tas de choses à l'occasion
de sa promenade dans ce dans ce désert
de Reds à Chambourcy donc on va revenir
avec quelque chose de peut-être un petit
peu plus traditionnel a priori c'est
c'est le parc du château à
Montfort-l'Amaury alors c'est le parc du
château de Grousset effectivement à
Montfort-l'Amaury c'est pas tellement
plus traditionnel parce qu'en fait c'est
pareil c'est un parc de fabrique mais il
y a un château donc c'est un peu plus
classique et c'est au tour donc il y a
le parc paysager du château puis
effectivement il y a une tente tartare
il y a un pont vénitien donc on voyage
dans ce parc à travers les pays d'Europe
et lorsqu'on reste dans les Yvelines
c'est merveilleux n'est-ce pas on passe
d'un
des différents endroits de l'Europe on
va partir à l'autre bout du monde le
jardin d'illy un jardin que je trouve
très beau on va visiter la Chine cette
fois-ci c'est ça c'est un parc
traditionnel chinois donc c'est à
Saint-Rémy-l'Honoré c'est la
propriétaire madame chic qui fait
découvrir ce jardin avec à la fois du
végétal du minéral on apprend le langage
des plantes des pierres c'est
extraordinaire c'est très très dépaysant
puis il y a aussi tout un tas de bonsaï
qui vous pouvez découvrir même si vous
le souhaitez vous pouvez les acheter il
y a un parc qui va peut-être intéressé
un petit peu plus les amoureux et les
amoureux des roses du côté de la
Villette voilà de Villette attention
parce que la Villette non non on reste
dans les Yvelines quand même essayer du
côté de Villette c'est au sud de
Mantes-la-Jolie et donc j'aime beaucoup
le nom de ce parc c'est le parc du Clos
paradenia safrané en fait c'est une
roseraie oui oui je te trouve ça très
joli vous avez 200 espèces de rose les
propriétaires vous expliquent comment
ils entretiennent leurs différentes
roses très jolies perspective dans ce
parc donc on rencontre les propriétaires
qui qui vous permettent de faire
d'échanger avec eux leur petit truc et
puis aussi ça fera un nez pourquoi bah
parce que tout simplement il y a des
épices également dans ce parc donc ce
parc sera ouvert sur demande ça ne
l'était pas c'est ils sont ils ont
ouvert pour la première fois l'occasion
de parole de jardinier ils ont décidé de
faire partager leur passion à tout le
monde en ouvrant plus régulièrement sur
demande sûrement absolument dernier parc
on a parlé de plantes de fleurs là on va
aller vers le musée de l'arbre un petit
peu c'est ça c'est ça et c'est
l'arboretum de chèvrelou qui se trouve
au Chesnay et cet arboretum il a 2500
espèces d'arbres donc c'est un parc qui
est magnifique qui est extrêmement grand
on peut s'y promener même toute la
journée on peut hippique donc il
passait la journée il y a des serres des
serres tropicales alors elles sont
ouvertes que de temps en temps elles
étaient ouvertes la semaine dernière
vous pourrez peut-être avoir l'occasion
de les redécouvrir un autre moment mais
en attendant le parc est toujours est
toujours ouvert et il vous attend avec
vraiment un environnement exceptionnel
n'hésitez surtout pas à y aller ce
weekend il fait un temps magnifique
ouais allez profiter du soleil ce
weekend vous avez sinon jusqu'au 29
septembre pour profiter de tous les
jardins et parc du département vous
pourrez retrouver toutes les
informations sur internet sur le site
parole de jardinier.fr merci beaucoup
Sylvie Laona d'être passé sur le plateau
de TVfil et puis à bientôt pour de
nouvelles découvertes dans le
département merci après sa gamme
d'épicerie fine le château de Versailles
on reste dans les châteaux lance
désormais sa bande dessinée cette
semaine sortait le tome 2 l'ombre de
Marie-Antoinette ou quand l'histoire se
mélange à la fiction claire Cambier et
Élodie moine
une plongée dans l'univers du château de
Versailles du 18e siècle c'est ce que
nous propose cette bande dessinée
l'ombre de Marie-Antoinette le tome 2
d'un triptyque sur le château l'histoire
d'un jeune Américain qui se retrouve
propulsé en pleine révolution française
alors quoi de plus naturel que de
présenter cet ouvrage sur les lieux même
de l'histoire scénariste dessinateurs et
éditeurs étaient hier au Grand Trianon
mais ce lieu leur était déjà bien
familier car tous les décors de cette
bande dessinée sont identiques à
l'original le pavillon dans lequel on se
trouve justement sur le tome 1 il m'est
arrivé de refaire justement les carreaux
de fenêtres parce qu'à l'époque il y en
avait deux fois plus donc ça n'a pas
échappé aux yeux du conservateur
un attachement au détail historiques
mais également au fait un conservateur
du château à aiguiller les auteurs sur
les deux tomes réalisés car ce triptyque
est co-édité par les éditions Glénat et
le château de Versailles habituellement
plus porté sur des ouvrages d'histoire
leur volonté était d'ouvrir un petit peu
un public plus large avec ce support qui
est la bande dessinée qui est donc un
art assez populaire on va dire
la volonté aussi de ne pas présenter
quelque chose de purement historique
mais la bande dessinée permet de
fictionner des événements donc de
rentrer dans un univers
où la petite histoire
rencontre la grande histoire nous
retrouverons ce mélange des genres pour
un dernier volet cette fois dans le
cercle de Molière
ils ont entre 11 et 15 ans et jouent au
grand chef derrière les fourneaux les
jeunes vers des rois participent au
concours Un dîner presque parfait et
pour la première étape de sélection ce
mercredi il devait réaliser le meilleur
dessert Yolaine Torres et Jonathan
Wilman ont surveillé les cuissons
ils ont 45 minutes montre en main pour
réaliser le meilleur dessert les
adolescents disposent de feuilles de
brick de poire et de chocolat une
recette que certains découvrent la
plupart du temps c'est plutôt kebab
pizza et grignotage une tendance que la
mairie de La Verrière veut enrayer à
travers cette initiative quand on leur
posait la question mais pourquoi vous
mangez ça souvent la réponse c'est des
questions de facilité c'est prêt en deux
minutes on se casse pas la tête c'est ce
qu'on a dans le frigo alors que là à
travers ce petit projet de lancement où
il est leur montrer qu'avec des aliments
simples on pouvait faire des choses en
quelques minutes et qu'en plus on
pouvait aussi varier l'alimentation les
jeunes apprentis ont tous entre 11 et 15
ans Janice et Mohamed font équipe
ensemble et ils sont plutôt confiants
comme j'aime bien la cuisine j'aime bien
cuisiner et j'ai pris cette occasion
pour montrer mon talent de cuisiner sur
sur quoi en fait
présentation on a assuré on va mettre du
chocolat fondu en zigzag on va mettre
des morceaux concassés sur le
porteur de l'assiette
en cuisine on s'active
le dessert prend forme petit à petit
puis vient leur des dernières retouches
les deux animateurs notent chaque
assiette de manière impartiale
8 pour ma part
sur les cinq équipes hier trois ont
gagné le ticket qui donne accès à la
grande finale le 27 septembre pour les
retardataires une deuxième sélection est
prévue mercredi prochain l'occasion de
tenter sa chance pour rencontrer les
professionnels qui constitueront le jury
de la grande finale
vous les avez peut-être vu traverser nos
routes le week-end dernier les DeLorean
les Renault alpines ou encore les deux
chevaux c'était donner rendez-vous pour
la 25 27e édition d'automotor rétro
Olivier Maniscalco et Jonathan wilmann
ont rencontré ses passionnés de voitures
d'un autre temps
la 27ème édition Automoto rétro se
tenait le week-end dernier sur le site
du château de La Coudre à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux amateur et
promeneur était au rendez-vous pour
apprécier le vrombissement des moteurs
et les belles carrosseries parmi eux Luc
collectionneur du Val-de-Marne et
propriétaire d'une Renault vivacis de
1931 c'est la toute première fois que je
défile oui sur cette journée il y avait
énormément de manifestations qui sont
tout au long de l'année bon on fait pas
on les fait pas toutes forcément mais
on en fait quand même relativement
souvent quand l'occasion se présente
alors la passion de l'automobile c'est
c'est un jour on se trouve avec ses
parents on est sur la route et puis on
voit un engin un petit peu particulier
comme dit mais c'est quoi et puis après
on épluche et puis un jour ben on ouvre
la porte d'un garage et il y en a une
qui sortent à vous donc bah vous faites
le pape puis voilà passion j'irai plus
une folie
une folie parce que tous
nos collectionneurs quels qu'il soit
c'est forcément une grande folie toute
la matinée chrome on rutilé le long des
routes de Montigny au château de
Versailles avec un arrêt au Petit
Trianon Mustang 2 chevaux alpine
traction et autres mg composé d'un
cortège de près de 200 voitures sur
l'ensemble de la journée
les arcisiens peuvent désormais profiter
de leur grand écran un cinéma vient
d'ouvrir ses portes à la Grange et
proposera une douzaine de projections
par semaine le tout en numérique
Catherine zulato et Patrick Jacques
Delic Smith
les images de la première séance du
cinéma de Bois-d'Arcy monstre Academy
pour accompagner les 35 premiers
spectateurs qui attendaient l'ouverture
avec impasse
on peut pas aller forcément à Versailles
ou à Saint-Quentin donc là c'est attendu
puis vu le contexte la médiathèque est
bien le centre de loisirs est bien donc
là on attend que ça on est ravi de cette
ouverture parce que un cinéma de
proximité comme ça c'est super
intéressant on peut venir à pied
les tarifs on les relativement attractif
donc c'est un peu plus familial qu'un
gros que le gros cinéma de Saint-Quentin
donc c'est une très bonne nouvelle
la Villa donc dorénavant son cinéma de
manière permanente installée à Lagrange
332 places disponibles de 10 à 12
projections par semaine et le double
pendant les vacances scolaires on a
trois styles de programmation d'avoir du
cinéma grand public voilà tous les films
qui sortent actuellement les grands
films une partie arsc qui est un peu
plus pointue et puis du cinéma jeune
public puisque voilà donc on a cette 3
axes de programmation une fois par mois
seront également proposés des ciné
goûter des ciné rencontres le tout doté
des dernières innovations technologiques
le vieux projecteur 35 mm supplantés par
le fameux 4K fini les bobines place au
tout numérique aujourd'hui on reçoit un
disque dur on l'insère dans notre base
de données qui a une librairie un plus
gros disque dur une fois qu'on l'a
inséré il repart et nous après on nous
envoie une clé pour débloquer ce disque
dur parce qu'il est crypté on peut pas
le diffuser tant qu'on n'a pas eu cette
clé et après c'est simple il suffit
d'appuyer sur play et puis c'est parti
la salle de cinéma est municipale elle
intègre le réseau local premier plan lui
permettant de diffusion pour les
scolaires les tarifs sont compris entre
4 et 6 euros
cette année le festival Orphée fête ses
10 ans un anniversaire pendant lequel
les représentations comédie musicale ou
opéra seront retranscrites en langue des
signes auraitrelia Debussy vous fait
découvrir ce nouveau festival
pour ses 10 ans le festival Orphée
réserve de belles surprises théâtre et
dense sont à l'honneur mais pas
seulement l'édition 2013 et l'occasion
d'ouvrir la scène à de nouveaux champs
d'expression tels que la comédie
musicale ou encore l'opéra en langue des
signes une première en France Orphée
œuvre à la promotion du handicap sous
toutes ses formes et cette année donne
un nouvel élan à son projet ce
rendez-vous annuel jusqu'ici présenté au
Théâtre Montansier à Versailles
s'élargit désormais à 6 espaces en
Île-de-France pour l'ouverture Frédéric
Zeitoun connu du petit écran pour ses
chroniques musicales nous raconte son
histoire une création en avant-première
qui traite avec humour et tendresse du
handicap la cinquantième bougie sur le
gâteau et le fait d'être nouvellement
papa m'ont donné envie de dire des
choses peut-être de transmettre je me
suis dit que j'avais peut-être un petit
peu voix au chapitre un petit peu une
petite fenêtre de tir pour pouvoir
parler donc autant bah oui donc j'ai
parlé de ma vie avec comme comme seul et
unique moteur c'est vrai vraiment on a
avec avec François des pneus avec qui
j'ai écrit ce spectacle en fait on a on
a écrit à quatre mains tout le tout le
livret et les chansons je les ai écrit
tout seul pour les paroles et j'ai
demandé de l'aide à certains amis
compositeurs qui généreusement je pense
à Charles Aznavour notamment qui nous a
fait cadeau de de musique et dans ce
spectacle ce qui est donc un spectacle
tout en en
partie en gaieté en musique en
émotion aussi qui une des rares voire
même sans doute première fois au monde
forment utilisée pour raconter
la réalité de la vie de Frédéric Zeitoun
une vie pas tout à fait comme les autres
que partage ses artistes professionnels
en situation de handicap le festival
Orphée n'a plus à démontrer que tout est
possible le handicap peut amener à une
création artistique différente car
n'est-ce pas seul la différence qui
compte lorsque l'on parle de création
dans votre émission culturelle kiosque
Nicolas Gervais a rencontré Dany
Lapointe et dîner qui dans leur
spectacle rend un hommage décalé abobi
la pointe vous savez c'est ce célèbre
chanteur de calembour des années 50 on
savait qu'on avait envie de choisir des
artistes qui ont univers éloigné de
celui de Boby Lapointe et qui
réinterprète totalement ses chansons on
voulait pas faire un énième hommage à la
façon de il y a eu une mise en
quarantaine une
marinade qu'on a fait dans les Landes où
chacun sur le répertoire nouveau Mickey
très petit sur une carrière avec un écho
énorme avoir 53 chansons
c'est vraiment rien du tout et dans
cette dans ce répertoire là les cinq les
six que nous étions au début maintenant
les 8 les 9
il s'est avéré que comme un vestiaire
chacun on est allé vers un beau mec qui
nous ressemblerait ne pas aller vers
notre Bobigny à nous je dis que l'amour
me sens âme c'était quand même l'amour
qu'on prend un petit peu
besoin que mon Marcel ça n'est qu'un
Manu elle connaît rien que ses mains qui
font des choses bien d'ailleurs moi j'ai
pas le temps de savoir qui est Marcel
car mon harcèle il me harcèle Marcel
meurt c'est Marcel me harcèle c'est
comme si la vie
en facette évidemment qui sont la
drôlerie même si c'est en permanence lié
à l'humour
la mort l'amour le cul même on va dire
le sexe nos univers propres sont
tellement différents que
il fallait aller très vite pour se
rencontrer pour se respecter et puis
pour être irrévérencieux aussi envers
Bobby la pointe qui était quand même
quelqu'un qui était atypique qui était
un peu subirif qui était un peu que
pauvre
à mon avis qui était un peu
anticonformiste qui avait cette endroit
là donc le fait que l'on passe du temps
à travailler ensemble on a surtout
appris à s'apprécier
et puis et accompagner la proposition de
l'autre sans la juger
pour Paris où j'ai eu pas mal de mal à
faire je suis de ma malade
je suis ici depuis que j'ai mal du pays
je vais dans le journal Voir l'aurore
boréale
mais pas dit que j'y vais
j'ai assisté à la résidence et c'est
vraiment avec avec grand plaisir que
j'ai vu se construire les choses
j'étais très touchée
du travail qui a été fait de
l'interprétation qui a été donnée je
trouve que ça donne une vision vraiment
différente de ces moderniser évidemment
ça donne une autre écoute aux chansons
depuis le temps que je t'attends depuis
le temps qui est une chanson faite par
Anne Sylvestre chanté par Roland Bourbon
et Evelyne Gallet quand on a Évelyne
Gallet qui chante le premier couplet qui
prend la voix d'Anne Sylvestre on a
quelque chose de puissance sérieux et on
a un Roland Bourbon qui ne change rien
mais à le voir tout d'un coup il nous
donne quelque chose de pas sérieux donc
ça crée un chemin assez troublant ça
devait être que de concert au début dans
chaque festival ça aurait été très très
bien et puis voilà ce qui séduit c'est
évidemment cette idée de bonne humeur
cette transmissible quoi une jolie MST
quoi
en baseball la semaine dernière nous
évoquions la double défaite des cougars
dans leur demi-finale aller de Division
2 face à Pessac dos au mur les
inimymontins ne devaient plus perdre
pour espérer voir la finale nous avons
suivi leur préparation et ce match copré
retour avec Jonathan Wilman
après le froid de cet hiver et la longue
interruption de l'été avant les playoffs
les organismes minimumontins semblent
usés mais à quelques jours d'une
demi-finale retour décisive Arnaud Fall
entraîneur des cougars préfèrent oublier
la déception du match aller et va tout
faire pour remobiliser ses joueurs tout
le monde est peut-être un petit peu
fatigué oui mais une finale ça vaut le
coup quoi
motivé on peut pas motiver quelqu'un qui
ne l'est pas mais je suis sûr qu'ils
sont tous un petit peu motivés est-ce
que je vais essayer de faire c'est de
les rallumer la petite flamme qu'ils ont
pour match aller cette petite flamme
avait quitté les inhymontins manquant
d'agressivité de précision ils se sont
inclinés par deux fois Pessac des
demi-finales de Division 2 se joint au
meilleur des cinq matchs les cougars ne
doivent plus perdre pour espérer voir la
finale complètement de au mur il faut
gagner 3 matchs donc c'est pas fini on
est encore là on a joué chez eux on va
jouer chez nous on a quand même qu'elle
j'allais dire tout mais non on a
quelques points de notre côté quand même
la survie des cougars passe d'abord par
un premier match couperait ce samedi
après-midi pour ne pas vivre une fin de
saison cauchemardesque
dès les premiers lancés le sort
s'acharne sur les cougars en plus du
handicap de deux matchs à remonter des
trombes d'eau s'abattent sur Jean
maréchalots
sur une journée quasiment du jamais vu
le lendemain gonflé comme des cocottes
minutes les inhymontins s'impose
finalement dans ce premier match 12
points 2 bis répétita dans la seconde
rencontre 13-2 en faveur des joueurs
d'Arnaud faux les homeron s'enchaînent
et tout le peuple 51ois alors à
l'exploit mais les cougars entament mal
ce match décisif et dans la 8e manche un
défenseur de Pessac réalise un catch
magnifique qui donne la victoire au
panthère 6 5 la marge de la finale aura
été trop haute pour les ini-montins qui
pourront regretter longtemps leur rater
du match aller
après une montée en Fédérale une les
féminines de l'AS Montigny rugby et ont
cessé leur entente avec Poissy cet été
elle repart de divisions plus bas avec
la volonté de retrouver l'élite le plus
vite possible Jonathan Wilman a initié
sa caméra dans les coulisses de leur
préparation d'intersaison
c'est par là que le chemin doit passer
les exercices de plaquage de percussion
et mise au point des combinaisons
amener des choses le plus rapidement
possible puisqu'on a pas intermédiaire
des confirmé des débutants donc il faut
tendre à niveau assez rapidement la
saison dernière les inhy Montaigne
avaient réussi l'exploit de monter en
fédéral une mais longtemps avec Poissy
s'est arrêté résultat Montigny a été
relégué en Fédérale 3 les 5 continents
veulent retrouver leur place en
championnat de France pour cela ils
pourront s'appuyer sur un pack d'avant
très solide une charnière expérimentée
qui a connu le haut niveau et sur leur
solidarité
un petit groupe assis soudé donc
certaines filles ça fait déjà quelques
années qu'on jouait ensemble donc on est
assez assez soudé on a une bonne
ambiance on se fait bah hier soir on a
fait une une soirée ensemble et
maintenant ça se passe toujours très
bien avec le renfort de 4 jours
Montigny semblable pour voir les
playoffs de Fédérale 3 la saison
dernière les filles de denifero non
connu la défaite qu'à une seule reprise
et pour terminer ce 7 8 week-end je vous
propose quelques rendez-vous à noter
tout d'abord côté culture ce samedi vous
pourrez vous rendre à partir de 15
heures à la Meuse à trappe pour un signe
des bas sur le Mali avec la projection
du documentaire La guerre des cotons en
sport pour les amateurs de sensations et
d'équilibre vous pourrez aller voir la
crème du trial français et mondial à
l'Open de trial zone le club de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux si vous avez envie
de découvrir la PTK un mélange de
volley-ball et de badminton et de tester
vos capacités physiques la deuxième
édition de sentez-vous sport vous
accueillera samedi et dimanche entre 14h
et 18h30 et enfin ce dimanche et
l'encours accueille le Grand Prix de
Paris un tournoi international d'échecs
les parties les toutes premières parties
débuteront à 15h ce 7 8 week-end touche
à sa fin la semaine prochaine dans
kiosque votre émission culture dont vous
avez l'habitude Aurélia Debussy à
recevra le Haras national de bréviaire
pour leur spectacle son et lumière pour
ma part je vous retrouverai dans le 7 8
sport avec Stéphane paysan l'entraîneur
de l'AS Montigny handball qui débute
leur saison de national de ce week-end à
Plouvorn avec un effectif bouleversé à
l'intersaison d'ici là excellent weekend